so what you get asked to do in number
three
is the complement of k
minus the complement of l okay so you
have to wrap your hand around
individually what they are
and then what does it mean to take a
difference okay and don't forget what
matters okay
so what i've got here these two diagrams
this bottom one this is the complement
of k
you can see i've shaded everything
except for maybe it's a bit hard to see
k is this left hand circle okay so i've
shaded everything except for the
left-hand circle except for k
that's the complement of k not k here is
conversely
the complement of l right now if it's
this minus this what i do
is i want to unshade everything in this
diagram
that is shaded here i want to unshade
everything here
that is shaded here okay so i go through
this one step
at a time for instance let's look at
let's look big first let's look at the
universal set
the stuff outside knl this universal set
arranged
is shaded right so it's shaded here so i
should take it away from this diagram
so i'm going to do that so there we go
so that's left me with k l there you go
i've just unshaded all that
part that doesn't belong to kol okay
so i've accounted for that what else is
shaded in the complement of l
and the answer is this part is also
shaded i haven't looked at that
right except you don't need to worry
about that because that's not shaded
down here anywhere
so i've done the subtraction now i've
taken a difference and what is left
is this part and the numbers in there
are 4 and 18.
does that make sense so go about it
slowly think carefully about what each
component means
and then think about the operation that
goes between them okay